il
[Musique]
mais chez roussel
merci madame la présidente c'est un
sous-amendement de précision visant à
remplacer le mot ne conduise par
n'aboutisse pour améliorer cette
excellente amendement de nos collègues
socialistes concernant les indépendants
je voudrais bien sûr en préambule
rappeler que si nous soudain mon don de
cette manière c'est parce que le
président ferrand a délibérément décidé
de supprimer 1184 amendements déposés
par les députés communistes ce qui est
une première
soum cette vème république nous pensions
que ce genre de procédé à l'égard des
communistes n'existait plus dans notre
pays
malheureusement c'est une nouvelle fois
mise en oeuvre et nous espérons avoir
tous les éclaircissements qu'il faut
pour réparer cette ignominie cette
injustice à l'égard de notre formation
politique
vous avez dit s'il vous plaît vous avez
dit concernant les indépendants puisque
c'est l'objet de ce sous un moment et
nous allons en utiliser autant qu'il le
faut pour éclairer nos concitoyens sur
la réalité de votre loi qui va faire du
mal comme jamais que vous allez lycée la
hausse des cotisations pour ces
indépendants sur 15 20 ans vous allez
lycée la hausse avec un régime
transitoire qui va s'étaler sur une
vingtaine d'années oui c'est vrai parce
que la régression sociale ça s'étale
quand ça fait mal et c'est ce que vous
êtes obligés de faire alors cette
régression sociale
vous allez l'appliquer aussi à travers
les indépendants à ces centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui ont des contrats
hubert dès l'hiver ou ceux qui
travaillent au coup de j'ai donné
quelques chiffres tout à l'heure mais
mes collaborateurs ont tenu à me
rappeler la réalité de ces chiffres le
nombre de créations d'entreprises en
france a augmenté de 17 9% par rapport à
et sur cet os 8 115 mille entreprises
ont été créées contre 691 en 2018 et
bien sûr ces 8 115 mille entreprises
créées sachez que le nombre
micro-entreprises d'effectifs et c'est
très important 386 1300m héricy micro
entreprise soit quasiment une sur deux
ce sont tous ces contrats hubert ces
mauvaises nouvelles et puis il fallait
demander de travailler jusqu'à 65 ans
merci le sous-amendement 41 1858 de
monsieur dharréville oui merci madame la
présidente toujours cette constance de
notre part à défendre le principe de non
régression sociale et à vouloir
l'inscrire dans la loi
nous pensons que si cette loi et devait
effectivement on aurait tout les les
magnifiques les mirifiques les
mirobolants d'intention que vous lui
attribuez eh bien il faut au moins vu
inscrire clairement cet objectif de non
régression sociale monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure je vous ai posé des
questions sur le sujet et j'ai pas eu
tout à fait le sentiment que vous m'ayez
pour l'instant répondu mais je ne
désespère pas et je voudrais en a ajouté
une passe concernant les professions
libérales dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
on a évoqué à juste titre les avocats il
y en a d'autres mais la mobilisation des
avocats vous l'avez constaté est une
mobilisation qui se poursuit
elle est massive elle aussi est
d'ailleurs à tel point que madame la
ministre de la justice garde des sceaux
a été obligée de leur écrire en
reconnaissant que ça évidemment ça pose
des problèmes au système de justice et
le principe de ces le principe de la
grève c'est à dire que quand les gens
s'arrêtent de travailler évidemment leur
travail n'est plus fait évidemment ça
pose un certain nombre de problèmes mais
s'ils cessent le travail c'est parce que
il estime que le contrat dans lequel ils
se sont engagés est rompu et menacés ou
qu'ils souhaitent légitimement
l'améliorer en l'occurrence il considère
qu' il ya une rupture par rapport à ce
qui avait été initialement prévu donc
moi je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre
est-ce que vous avez une idée je pense
que si vous n'en avez pas il faut
retirer la réforme
est-ce que vous avez une idée de
l'évolution du taux de rendement de la
cotisation par exemple des avocats
est-ce que vous avez une idée du taux de
rendement de l'évolution du taux de
rendement des professions libérales avec
votre
je sais bien que ça ne fait pas partie
de vos préoccupations puisque ça va être
la variable d'ajustement permanente que
les pensions vont être la variable
d'ajustement permanente avec l'âge de
départ mais je crois que vous ne pouvez
pas aller au bout de cette réforme sans
prendre des engagements sans donner au
minimum une trajectoire qui n'existe pas
dans votre étude d'impact merci monsieur
dharréville le 42 1206 madame autun oui
oui c'est un sous-amendement à
l'excellente amendement de nos collègues
socialistes qui interroge au fond le
gouvernement sur le caractère régressif
de son projet de loi
on a eu un débat en commission monsieur
turquois doit s'en souvenir justement
sur la notion de progrès social un
progrès social c'est quand on améliore
la situation or là il y à de très
nombreux secteurs qui sont mobilisés
parce qu'ils ont bien compris qu'avec
votre réforme on aller dans une grande
régression c'est à dire un moins disant
de leur situation avec des éléments très
préoccupant pour certaines catégories de
la population les fonctionnaires je les
dis et je le répète puisque avec le
calcul sur les six derniers mois le taux
de remplacement va chuter de 32% ou
d'autres catégories qu'on a vu
particulièrement mobilisés je pense aux
avocats qui voit bien que avec la
cotisation supplémentaire que vous leur
demander de prendre en charge vont voir
leur profession en très grande
difficulté et ce ne sont pas les grands
avocats qui vont payer le prix mais
évidemment les avocats qui sont au plus
près des populations qui ont le moins
d'argent donc c'est le droit à l'accès à
la justice qui l'a être menacé du même
coup d'eau cette cet amendement et ces
sous-amendements vise tout simplement à
vous interpeller à vous interpeller
aussi dans la majorité pour bien évaluer
les répercussions sur des catégories
professionnelles importantes de notre
société
des mesures que vous prenez et qui vont
conduire à une immense régression
sociale et non pas à du progrès social
mais je pense qu'un petit problème avec
la macro ni dans la façon de penser
l'enjeu du progrès social merci madame
merci madame la députée oui monsieur
habib un rappel au règlement sur quels
fonds 3 monsieur habib
oui madame la présidente j'ai été mis en
cause par la députée autun
personnellement il me semble que le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
aurait évolué au minimum un minima
rappel à l'ordre à la député en question
de quoi s'agit-il
dans cet hémicycle madame la présidente
mes chers collègues et des députés de
trois parties des sénateurs de trois
partis politiques des ats-unis des
communistes et des écologistes qui ont
piétiné dans une parodie de lynchage la
marionnette du président de la
république devant l'assemblée nationale
avec l'écharpé tricolore
je crois à madame la présidente que
toutes les limites ont été franchies
je crois qu'après avoir mis le président
et je ne fais pas partie du prêt je fais
partie de l'opposition
je crois que madame la présidente
après avoir il ya quelques semaines mis
la tête du président de la république
sur une pique dans des manifestations à
paris il ya des limites qui ont été
déplacées elles ont été dépassés dans un
silence assourdissant
j'ai en mémoire la scène est tellement
rare prise de parole de robert badinter
qui prend tellement rarement la parole
et et qui a et qui a été dans une danse
dans une dans une parole rare et
magnifique a rappelé à rappeler que
derrière un symbole il y à la pulsion et
c'est pour ça que évidemment j'ai twitté
j'ai le droit tu t'es pas ce que c'était
sur l'air de à cause des garçons et j'ai
côté oui à cause des petite conne parce
que c'est bien le minimum qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse chainel j'ai listé des pc
mais c'est marrant c'est scandaleux ce
que vous faites c'est scandaleux vous
attiser la haine vous attiser la haine
monsieur monsieur le député alors une
observation oui une observation
oui d'abord je rappelle les règles si
vous le permettez je rappelle les règles
des rappels au règlement
s'il vous plaît chers collègues je
rappelle bon monsieur roussel monsieur
roussel
s'il vous plaît je vais vous donner la
parole madame autun je vais vous donner
la parole je voudrais simplement
rappeler s'il vous plaît je voudrais
rappeler les règles des rappels au
règlement vous devez indiquer sur quel
fondement se base le rappel au règlement
que vous faites si c'est une mise en
cause c'est au titre de l'article 58 il
faut le dire
ensuite je souhaiterais que dans cet
hémicycle des injures ne soit pas
proférer donc madame madame autun vous
avez demandé à rappeler le règlement sur
quel fondement madame l'article 58 pour
mise en cause personne vient alors à la
ruse écoutons bon nous savons ici que
monsieur meyer habib ne pratique pas
l'humour mais la caricature en
permanence et l'insultent et donc je
maintiens mes propos traiter des
parlementaires de petite conne sur les
réseaux sociaux est à la fois sexiste et
insultant quant à ce que nous avons fait
un monsieur meyer habib calmez vous
prenez un petit peu de camomille ça vous
fera du bien
on reste de ne jamais y est la faucille
et nous pourrions s'il vous leurrez
faire en effet nous avons chanté
nous avons dansé nous avons parodier
nous avons contesté
c'est un droit démocratique fondamental
que peuvent exercer les citoyennes et
les citoyens et que peuvent exercer les
élus dans leurs fonctions
parce que oui nos fonctions c'est de
défendre ici nos idées et d'être si le
font dans des manifestations pour dire
quelles sont nos convictions et quand
nous contestons nous pouvons le faire
avec de la joie de la bonne humeur et un
esprit critique qui me semble-t-il est
un des éléments forts de toute
démocratie qui se respecte
alors je regrette que monsieur meyer
habib ne trouve rien d'autre à faire que
d'insulter une nouvelle fois et monsieur
meyer habib
j'aimerais bien un jour que vous soyez
là pour débattre du fond j'aimerais bien
que nous débattions en effet du fonds
sans injures sans insultes est ce un
sexisme mais je pense que ça vous
demanderai un effort qui est hors de
votre portée bien merci madame automne
je vais donner la parole à madame buffet
mais je voudrais simplement vous dire
qu'un fait personnel répondant un autre
fait personnel on peut enchaîner ainsi
les prises de paroles donc madame buffet
a rappelé le règlement sur quel
fondement il ya 58 parties que 58 alinéa
chers collègues vous faites honte à la
république par vos propos vous
n'acceptez pas vous n'acceptez pas que
des mobilisations existe auprès de
l'assemblée dans la joie et la bonne
humeur vous n'acceptez pas que des
femmes se lèvent pour dire ce qu'elle
pense vous les rabaisser par vos propos
sexistes et vulgaire et je peux vous
dire monsieur que votre comportement
donne à voir aussi de votre pensée
politique pas très grande mais un
monsieur quatre ans
oui je vais demander une suspension de
séance à la présidence mais je voudrais
dire d'abord à notre collègue a bible
qu'il vient d'inventer en quelque sorte
le délit de lynchage symbolique
collègues
la satire la caricature ça existe et
parce que contrairement à vous nous
sommes des républicains convaincus et
conséquent nous sommes opposés à la
violence en politique
effectivement
oui et nous l'avons toujours été nous
l'avons toujours dit et dansé autour
d'une marionnette ou faire une
chorégraphie
ça a d'abord une portée symbolique en
revanche traiter les parlementaires de
petite conne ça n'a plus une portée
symbolique
c'est une insulte et c'est intolérable
c'est vous qui faites honte à la
république
je demande une suspension de séance tant
que le collègue habib n'aura pas
présenté des excuses pour avoir insulté
des parlementaires bien elle et elle est
de droit je vous l'accordé mais je
voudrais donner la parole pour deux
rappels au règlement
à monsieur au bercail monsieur woerth je
suis merci même le président sur la base
de l'article 70 de règlement qui
rappelle jeu que d'abord on ne doit pas
faire interpeller un autre député ou
l'injurier dans le cas de l'assemblée ça
c'est le troisième est l'idéal est le
cinquième qu'on ne doit pas se rendre
coupable d'injures de provocation
devenait à savoir le président de la
république
les deux ont été commises l'une sur
twitter l'autre sur le parvis de
l'assemblée nationale moi j'aimerais un
moment donné que les le fonctionnement
de cette assemblée ne soient pas
mobilisés par une partie de ping pong
qui peut très bien se régler en dehors
de l'hémicycle et que à un moment donné
madame le président voulait on en tire
les conséquences
par rapport au blocage parce que ça peut
continuer très loin si on continue ainsi
on peut passer la nuit ou la journée et
nous avons des éléments de fond et
beaucoup de français qui attendent qu'on
ait une réforme des retraites
monsieur monsieur aubert c'est
précisément ce que je viens de dire
monsieur le président verte oui je vais
là même mêmes bases face aux articles 77
articles sont justes mais la présidente
je voudrais ajouter ce qu'a dit mon
collègue aubert on va pas aller de
tweets en tweets comme il ya un moment
donné ça suffit et d'ailleurs les tweets
sont en train de s'imposer aux articles
ce qui est quand même pose un tout petit
problème
je pense que nous n'avons pas non plus
être pris en otage entre les insoumis
qui en rajoute tout le temps et puis et
puis un député qui s'estiment qui
s'estime insultée
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas notre histoire
et c'est pas l'histoire d'air c'est pas
l'histoire de la réforme des retraites
nous devons parler du fond et dieu sait
qu'il ya lire on a des centaines et des
centaines et des centaines d'amendements
adore donc sortait de l'hémicycle
discuter ensemble régler cela dans la
presse mais pas devant l'émission miam
et si monsieur woerth alors je vais je
vais suspendre la séance en dents vous
disant mes chers collègues que les
points de vue se sont exprimés les
rappels au règlement et des faits dont
on va suspendre et on reprendra l'examen
des sous-amendements après la suspension
de trois minutes
ouais
mais bien la séance et reprises un
pardon monsieur le ministre mais pas les
bras tant que ministre
la séance est reprise alors le
sous-amendement 40 2206 qui le défend
mal à me ruban en fait votre loi dont
vous vous félicitez qu'elles assurent
une pension minimum de 85 % du smic pour
tous ce que j'appelle finalement une
obole
eh bien elle va toucher de plus en plus
de personnes et notamment les
indépendants à l'image du monde que vous
nous préparer c'est à dire un monde
d'indépendants de précarité on a parlé
on a évoqué les hubert et tous les auto
entrepreneurs
alors moi je comprends surtout que votre
réforme avec ces minimums avec ses au
bol est à l'image donc du monde du
travail que vous préparez et en ce sens
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit un
progrès social
de la même manière que travailler
jusqu'à soins 65 ans et que vous appelez
d'un progrès social et bien pour nous
c'est une régression de plus d'un siècle
alors je ne vois pas j'aimerais vraiment
comprendre ou où se situe le progrès
social dont vous voyez dont vous vous
félicitez temps dans cette dans cette
réforme il m'aide à me rubin le 41 1863
monsieur jumelles jeune ministre
chaque jour qui passe je me demande qui
soutient votre réforme plus personne
pour soutenir votre réforme
le medef appels à son retrait l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales sont vent
debout
delvoie s'est envolé et fait du tri dans
ses papiers et l'ensemble des
professions chaque jour dénonce les
turpitudes de votre mauvais projet
devant la fronde des libéraux vous avez
un sortie en commission spéciale un
système pour permettre au régime
d'affiliation de décider s'il souhaite
utiliser leurs réserves financières afin
de faciliter la convergence vers le
barème de cotisation du système
universel autrement dit vous avez
envisagé de faire en sorte que
les indépendants prennent sur leurs
réserves pour payer plus
en ayant une pension dégrader avec votre
système indépendant qui cotisera à 1500
euros par ans touchera la même retraite
que celui qui cotise 6200 euros
c'est ce système vous le savez va être
aussi une trappe à favoriser le travail
dissimulé puisque un indépendant qui
aura vocation à venir s'installer va
vouloir échapper aux cotisations
prohibitifs que vous allez mettre en
place c'est donc la triple peine pour
les professions dont on parle et vous
êtes dans l'incapacité d'apporter mes
balles allant si tu veux parler tu prend
le micro tu es tu fais comme nous tu
veux tu essaies trouver des arguments
entre vous s'il vous plaît non je
continue en disant que vous peinez à
défaut de vociférer à trouver des
arguments étayés consolidé pour répondre
aux argumentations du développement mais
à le 41 1869 monsieur dharréville merci
madame la présidente
j'ai entre les mains un communiqué qui
parle de 12 février 2020 un communiqué
des caisses différentes caisses
autonomes de professions libérales et
monsieur le ministre je pense que le
parlement doit être informé de ce que
vous prévoyez précisément les concernant
des de l'état d'avancement des
discussions parce que sinon nous ça veut
dire que nous légiférons sans être
informés éclairé réellement je crains
d'ailleurs que ce soit le cas sur bien
des sujets et donc ils disent
la chose suivante ils se sont réunis
tous toutes les caisses de retraite se
sont se sont réunis avec celle des
avocats pour faire réaliser leurs
propres études d'impact et il conteste
les chiffres que vous vous avez indiqué
donc moi je voudrais savoir si on a
réussi à élucider un petit peu ce qu'il
en est réellement
concernant les chiffres parce que on
peut sinon ça signifie que nous nous
avons un défaut d'information manifeste
et puis il demande à ce qu'un certain
nombre d'engagements que vous auriez
pris soit inscrit dans la loi
moi je voudrais monsieur ministre
connaître vos intentions précises en la
matière merci monsieur le député le 41
1864 monsieur d'arrivée le monsieur
brunel
merci madame la présidente je voudrais
m'exprimer sur la promesse de votre
forme de renforcer la liberté de choix
pour partir à la retraite
je me demande si vous savez comment ça
se passe dans la vraie vie des
travailleurs je pense aux salariés des
verreries dans mon collègue sébastien
jumel a déjà ici parler de cette
profession de cette pénibilité de ces
travailleurs nous avons encore dans la
circonscription deux entreprises de à
venise qui était auparavant la capitale
du verre je vais vous parler ici des
gestes répétitifs des piétinements
permanent des postures compliqué des
régimes horaire est prêt et un temps qui
changent tout le temps c'est les 3 8 sél
et 4,8 c'est les 5 8
je peux vous décrire les ateliers où les
températures explosent avec la chaleur
des fours avec la poussière qui
s'incruste partout avec la manipulation
de produits toxiques pour la santé
je peux vous dire qu'ils m'expliquent
souvent les rendements qui augmente pour
produire toujours plus vite afin de
faire gagner un maximum d'argent
l'entreprise ou pensez vraiment que les
verriers sont libres de choisir de
travailler jusque 64 25 ans avec le
corps brisé le dos cassé et la santé
animé ou peut-être pensez-vous qu'ils
sont réellement libres de partir avant
l'âge d'équilibré avec des décotes de
pension intolérable pour des retraites
de misère la vie ce n'est pas le monde
de bisounours où on est libre de
travailler en mauvais santé entre le
fort et le faible entre le riche et le
pauvre entre le maître et le serviteur
c'est la liberté qui opprime et la loi
qui affranchit c'est pourquoi nous
continuons à demander une retraite à
taux plein à 60 ans notre pays est bien
la série pour la financer à condition de
mettre fin au régime spécial de la
finance
si monsieur le député le 41 1867
monsieur annoncé monsieur jumelles savez
dans le flaconnage de luxe l'ensemble
des les parfums que les uns et les
autres nous portons enfin quand on en a
les moyens
sur un flacon de parfum de soro le coût
du travail vers le coût de rémunération
des verriers dont on vient de parler
alain bruneel et 2 1 euros alors que la
valeur ajoutée de cette force travail
amène les flaques les flacco niel et les
verriers de luxe avant de ce flacon 100
euros c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voulons vous faire part de la pénibilité
des salariés verrier de la vallée de la
bresle chez moi en glass vallée 73
entreprises très mais 13000 verrier qui
à les y faire un tour un jour au bouchon
au pied du four 80° il fait écho kae
dufour et je vous assure que une journée
de labeur une vie de labeur aux bouchons
les trieuses de verre qui font parce que
ce sont essentiellement des femmes qui
font ce travail là et qu'ils trient les
flacons de parfum au bout de la chaîne
et bien je vous assure que proposer à
ces gens de travailler jusqu'à 65 ans à
66 cents à 67 ans sans prendre en compte
la pénibilité que leur travail
représente alors que il attache de la
fierté à leur travail est une insulte
est une humiliation est une
méconnaissance des points de vie en
bonne santé qui ne sont pas les mêmes en
fonction du métier que l'on occupe c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
faire rentrer cette vérité là aussi dans
le débat qui nous occupe vous vouliez
qu'on parle de fonds et bien voilà un
beau sujet de fond que je livre à votre
réflexion en lien avec mon collègue
alain bruneel merci monsieur le député
le 41 1873
monsieur dharréville oui merci à madame
la présidente je me permets de réitérer
une question que j'ai posée tout à
l'heure concernant les travailleurs des
plateformes dans cette économie berries
et qui cherche à se développer partout
sans entrave et qui donc cherche en
réalité à s'affranchir des droits
s'affranchir de cette part du salaire
qui sert à financer et bien la sécurité
sociale la protection sociale ce qu'on
appelle de salaire pour la vie c'est ça
le principe de libéralisation de
l'économie et de la diminution à
outrance de ce que certains appellent le
coût du travail mais pas nous voilà la
réalité des prix et nous pensons que là
en parlant de droits à la retraite
évidemment on touche un élément
extrêmement sensible qui est fortement
impacté par le développement de ce type
de formes de relations de travail et
donc nous pensons que ça doit appeler à
une remise en cause forte du
développement de ce type de
fonctionnement et je voudrais parce que
bien évidemment une fois que les uns les
autres arrivent à la retraite il faut
sans doute en tenir compte et je suis
pas sûr que vous ayez suffisamment fait
le travail pour cela mais ensuite je
crois qu'il faut s'attaquer à la source
du problème et nous demandons nous pour
l'essentiel que ces contrats soient
requalifiés en contrat de travail
lorsque la relation de subordination est
établi et je voudrais monsieur le
ministre connaître les intentions qui
sont les vôtres à l'égard de ces
travailleurs de des plateformes pour
leur garantir un véritable droit à la
retraite mais aussi pour leur garantir
une vie digne au travail merci monsieur
le député le 42 1246 monsieur catane ans
merci madame la présidente
on se rappelle que le nouveau ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand avait
souhaité dans la constitution
supprimer le terme de sécurité sociale
pour le remplacer par le terme de
protection sociale et le terme
protection sociale recouvre finalement
d'autre chose que la sécurité sociale la
sécurité sociale
disions hier c'est chacun cotise selon
ses moyens et reçoit selon ses besoins
la protection sociale elle inclut les
assurances privées
les complémentaires les mutuelles et
n'est donc pas sur la même logique
or précisément c'est exactement le même
mouvement qui se perd et donc on peut
bien parler de régression des droits
s'agissant de cette réforme des
retraites car en réalité à dessein ce
que vous souhaitez faire c'est faire en
sorte que parmi les 300 milliards
d'euros qui sont trop dix ans les
caisses de la sécurité sociale pour les
retraites une part considérable fui vers
les retraites par capitalisation et vous
le faites par plusieurs billets mais
évidemment d'abord par le fait d'un
abaissement du niveau de vie et du
niveau de pension des retraités
car en effet les deux contraintes que
vous posez les équilibres financiers
sont consacrés plus de richesse aux
retraites va obliger en quelque sorte à
ce que la variable d'ajustement soit la
baisse du niveau des pensions et je
redis et je redirai autant de fois qu'il
le faudra que baisser le niveau des
pensions ou augmenter l'âge effectif de
départ par le report de l'âge déquilibre
7h pivot qui à force d'ailleurs de se
décaler va davantage ressembler à un âge
qu'avocat un axe pivot eh bien c'est la
même chose que de baisser le niveau des
pensions
donc oui c'est un affaiblissement oui
c'est une régression et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous présentons ce
sous-amendement à l'amendement de notre
collègue socialiste
merci monsieur maintenance le 41 1876
monsieur dharréville merci madame la
présidente toujours un amendement de
précisions sur ce sujet des indépendants
qui va me permettre de dire quelques
mots sur la philosophie de votre
proposition et de votre système en
réalité il s'inscrit vraiment dans une
logique d'individualisation et de mise
en concurrence qui existe déjà que vous
avez déjà mise en oeuvre dans le cadre
du travail et de la vie active et qui va
se poursuivre y compris avec en
perspective la retraite puisque bon on
connaît un set cette idée qui avait été
défendu à l'époque par nicolas sarkozy
du travailler plus pour gagner plus avec
de plus en plus de difficulté finalement
à gagner sa vie en travaillant toujours
plus qui s'est installée dans notre
société et qui touche particulièrement
d'ailleurs les un certain nombre de
petits artisans et petits commerçants et
d'indépendants ils sont eux aussi soumis
à 7 à cette réalité
je crois qu'en avec le système par
points tel que vous le mettez en oeuvre
eh bien vous ajouter une dimension à
cette obligation quelque part qui leur
est fait de devoir toujours et bien
courir après un certain nombre
d'activités au mépris et bien de leur
propre existence et parfois de leur
santé pour pouvoir se garantir un
véritable droit à la retraite
au bout du compte donc moi j'ai entendu
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur une volonté de la majorité de
mieux prendre en compte la réalité des
des droits à la retraite des
indépendants des petits artisans des
petits commerçants
tonton c'est aujourd'hui la faiblesse
dans le système de protection sociale
actuelle donc c'est une réalité qu'il
faut constater mais je suis pas du tout
certain que le système que vous proposez
avec la philosophie qui est la sienne
permettent d'y répondre convenablement
merci monsieur le député le 41e 1879
monsieur jumelles sur le ministre chaque
heure qui passe chaque minute même j'ai
l'impression que votre tête s'enfonce
dans vos épaules et que vous vous dites
jusque là tout va bien jusque là tout va
bien
jusque là tout va bien mais qu'au bout
du compte il ya plus grand chose qui va
geoffroy roux de bézieux le président du
medef
non la vôtre au sortir de la conférence
de financement a dit sans équilibre
financier je m'opposerai à la réforme
des retraites
il poursuit alors que la conférence de
financement des retraites a démarré dans
les échos d'hier dans les échos d'hier
il dit face au gouvernement qui torti il
maintient que la réforme ne pourra se
faire sans réponse aux questions de
financement elle lui dit il sont mesures
d'âge et en plus ils envoient un pavé
dans la marre bien ex un explosif d'une
certaine manière votre soutien vous
envoie un explosif au pied un explosif
d'ailleurs au visage des salariés il dit
pour travailler sur la pénibilité
d'accord pour plus de départs anticipés
à condition de baisser le nombre de
départs de carrières longues
autrement dit la conférence de
financement est mort-né autrement dit
toute discussion sur la pénibilité est
enterré par le président des mets du
medef
autrement dit les leurs que vous avez
inventé pour faire avaler la pilule de
votre mauvaise réforme sont en train de
tomber un à un par ailleurs sur la
question de la baisse des cotisations
pour les cadres supérieurs il vous met
en garde sur le fait que ces cadres qui
sont dit-il la sève du dynamisme des
plus grandes entreprises vont être
fragilisés vont être amenés à se vautrer
vers les retraites par capitalisation et
qu'ils vont se retourner d'ailleurs
contre les entreprises pour faire monter
les enchères afin de les financer
monsieur le mini je comprends à la
faveur de ces bonnes nouvelles
pourquoi à chaque minute qui passe à
chaque heure qui passe votre tête
s'enfonce un peu plus dans vos épaules
alors 41 1883 monsieur d'artsevi
monsieur brunel et merci présidente
effectivement mon collègue sébastien
jumel a fait une démonstration brillante
comme quoi cette réforme
y a pas que des trous dans la raquette
il ya des trous dans le gruyère ya même
plus de bruit hier et même plus de
raquette parce qu'on ne sait pas où on
va
et ça c'est quand même important
puisqu'on doit discuter sur le fond mais
sur dix sculptures le fond c'est sûr
qu'elles font qu'on va discuter et là on
est en train de toucher véritablement le
fond alors dans l'amendement de monsieur
vallot il nous invite à regarder les
professions spécifiques et les
professions où le travail est pénible
mon collègue monsieur le fur a discuté
notamment nous alerter sur les
assistantes maternelles et de suite j'ai
pensé aussi aux aides à domicile qui est
une profession difficile profession
décalé où il est souvent c'est le
personnel féminin qui vont chez les
personnes âgées pour faire la toilette
pour faire le ménage ou faire à manger
pour les rassurer
elles vont le matin elles ont plusieurs
patients allaient voir et ses patients
les attendent avec effectivement
impatience parce que c'est quand même un
réconfort c'est quand même une est c'est
quand même une écoute et donc ces
professions qui travail de trois heures
le matin une heure l'après midi une
heure à 12h01 heure le soir
et souvent c'est dès mi temps et souvent
cédé mi temps parce que elles sont là
pour amener un peu de beurre dans les
épinards quand on dit chez moi parce que
le mari qui travaille n'a pas non plus
un salaire qui est important est donc
cette profession qui en profitent qui
travaillent une façon très pénible et
très décalée elle doit être connu dans
ce système de retraite est là tels que
vous proposez on sent pas vraiment une
profession qui considérait
merci monsieur le député le 42 1198
monsieur corbières merci madame la
présidente effectivement l'amendement du
collègue vallot qui introduit par écrit
la prise en compte de la pénibilité
quelque chose d'important et il me
semble que nous aurions gagné je le dis
comme un conseil à nos collègues dans
marchès que d'abord avant même de
commencer le débat sur cette réforme des
retraites et vous connaissez notre
opposition mais à ce que nous
redéfinissions clairement ce que sont
les critères de pénibilité
on se souvient tous que cette majorité a
souhaité retirer quatre critères de
pénibilité qui avait été mis en place
par le précédent gouvernement
les arguments étaient de dire que
souvent des employeurs s'ils perdaient
que ça n'était pas très clair etc
nous allons donc gagner à retravailler
par la suite en considérant qu'il existe
dans certains métiers une grande
pénibilité indiscutable qui a pour
conséquence la dégradation des corps des
femmes et des hommes qui travaillent est
effectivement monsieur le président la
pique 10 ans qui n'aimait balmont de
pénibilité pas ce que ça donnait
l'impression que le travail était
parfois pénible avouons que oui souvent
le travail est pénible et us les corps
donc nous aurions dû retravailler
cela n'a pas été fait et cela donne une
suspicion généralisée vis-à-vis du
projet de loi que nous proposer parce
que nous avons beaucoup argumenté que ce
soit dans l'hémicycle où ailleurs
souvent des collègues nous répond b nous
allons prendre en compte la pénibilité
mais nous ne savons toujours pas dans
quelle mesure donc c'est nécessaire me
semble-t-il d'introduire et d'accepter
l'amendement du collègue vallot et de re
préciser ces choses là
sans quoi bien évidemment l'ensemble des
travaux qui suivent reste assez confus
marquée par des promesses verbales mais
par aucune définition précise dans la
loi de ce que sont ces critères de
pénibilité
nous devons retravailler là dessus
l'usure des corps est quelque chose de
central la dureté du travail est une
réalité que nul ne peut nier et nous
devons dans la loi en le déclinant
ensuite dans la législation sociale le
code du travail précise et sur cette
affaire là cette absence de précision
est une tâche supplémentaire sur le
projet de loi que vous nous présentez
merci monsieur le député
le 41 1885 monsieur dharréville oui
merci madame la présidente donc toujours
sur cette question dès des indépendants
parmi les indépendants il n'aura échappé
à personne qui a un certain nombre de
deux statuts différents qui sont liées à
des activités qui ne sont pas les mêmes
avec certains qui sont obligés parfois
de faire beaucoup plus effectivement que
35 heures qui ne n'ont pas tous et
toutes les mêmes conditions de travail
au quotidien est donc évidemment un
régime de retraite doit tenir compte de
ces différences de ses spécificités qui
peuvent exister entre les indépendants
eux mêmes et elles mêmes or il s'avère
là que l'unification que vous proposez
et bien va pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux doublé leur leur montant de
cotisation et donc évidemment de fait
faire réduire de manière singulière
le taux de rendement de ses cotisations
donc tout à l'heure une fine est un
libéral devra cotiser voilà deux fois
plus qu'aujourd'hui pour percevoir une
pension de retraite revu à la baisse
moi je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre comment vous envisagez cette
difficulté face à ce système
prétendument universel que vous que vous
voulez mettre en oeuvre pour mémoire
quand même parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
des avocats pour un revenus excédant les
40000 euros le taux de cotisation donc
passerait à 12 points 94 %
les avocats ne sont pas nombreux à
percevoir un revenu excédant les 50000
euros
voilà donc je crois qu'il faut aussi
prendre en compte cette situation il ya
beaucoup d'avocats qui aujourd'hui bien
se trouve avec des revenus qui sont
modestes
voilà merci monsieur le député le 41
1886 monsieur jumelles
merci madame la présidente avec mon
copain rufin en commission des affaires
économiques depuis plusieurs mois nous
développons l'idée que dans cette
société des biens les métiers du lien
sont souvent la variable d'ajustement
des libéraux parmi ces métiers les
agresseurs qui prennent soin des enfants
en situation de handicap et dont le
rapport sur l'inclusion que j'ai eu
l'honneur de conduire démontrent que
plus de 80 % d'entre elles se voyaient
proposer des contrats de travail à durée
déterminée à temps partiel et à horaire
modules et comment en appliquant votre
système universel allez vous offrir une
retraite pour ses plus de 80000 à eux
est sage parmi ces métiers du lien les
atsem dans nos écoles maternelles qui
voient leur carrière
amputé par votre volonté de ne plus
faire référence aux six derniers mois
dans la fonction publique territoriale
parmi ces métiers du lien
les assistantes maternelles qui nous le
savons ont des horaires de travail très
faibles ondées variations de
mobilisation de travail très faible en
fonction des enfants qui naissent et des
parents qui font appel à elle comment
allez vous offrir à ces femmes qui font
un travail extraordinaire prendre soin
de nos enfants une retraite convenable
digne après une vie de travail parmi ces
métiers du lien les aides à domicile
vous avait flingué les départements
l'apa n'est pas financé les oui oui oui
vous avez flinguer les départements et
d'ailleurs la réforme fiscale va
aggraver cette situation est donc lapin
étant insuffisantes les aides à domicile
sont aujourd'hui profondément fragilisé
le temps de travail à durée déterminée à
horaires modulables et des situations
extrêmement précaire
quelles perspectives de retraite allez
vous offrir aux aides à domicile de ce
pays
alors moi je ne veux plus vous entendre
dire que les femmes seront les grandes
gagnantes de votre mauvaise réforme
je ne veux plus vous entends dire que
votre réforme est juste qu'elle est
solidaire quel et redistributive
je veux que vous entendrez pour la
question qui font la démonstration que
les patrons des grandes perdantes de
cette réforme à point parce que mexico
pendant la retraite s'excuser oui
monsieur coquerel le 42 milles 203 bien
par cet amendement nous voulons
souligner nous voulons parler de
l'espérance de vie
[Musique]
je vais attendre un petit peu s'il vous
plaît monsieur jumelles nous vous
reconnaissons vos qualités de chauffeur
de salle c'est un coup de feu stable
mais la parole est à présent à monsieur
coquerel oui s'il vous plaît monsieur
cochrane a demandé la parole et moi
monsieur je respecte le gène est plutôt
que les cris qui fusent très souvent de
la part la majorité vu qu'ils sont en
nombre
c'est beaucoup plus gênant pour tout le
monde sait ça vous avez été élu pour
vociférer dans l'assemblée nationale
jeudi vociférer ce que c'est le terme d'
à hyères fière de votre président votre
président d'assemblée nationale
vis-à-vis d'opposants donc je vais vous
parler d'un sujet qui révélera de vie
que nous voulons pointé à travers cet
amendement on observe que le seul
espérance de vie qui j'allais dire à un
intérêt parra pour voir combien de temps
on vit à partir de l'âge de la retraite
c'est l'espérance de vie à 60 ans on
observe que depuis dix ans il a stagné
il a stagné pendant que l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé lui carrément
reculait il est difficile de ne pas
faire un rapport entre ces stagnation et
ce recul est le fait que dans le même
temps et bien l'âge de départ à la
retraite à taux plein moyen n'a cessé en
réalité lui d'augmenter 61 en 2007 62 en
2011 63 ans aujourd'hui en 2019
or votre projet prévoit de l'augmenter
considérablement dans les années à venir
65 ans 68 ans en 2000 70 69 ans à la fin
du siècle et c est encore dans le
meilleur des cas ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que healy a évidemment un lien
entre l'âge à laquelle on part à la
retraite et donc
on s'arrête de travailler parce que je
ne crois pas en l'occurrence qu'on peut
bien vieillir au travail est la durée de
vie qu'on peut espérer une fois à la
retraite
votre projet est votre projet donc et
ont seulement à recul civilisationnel
mais il est en recul pour la santé
publique
il est un recul pour le progrès coffre
justement les progrès médicaux sur
l'espérance de vie et pour notre part
nous ne pensons pas je termine ma thune
ne pensons pas qu'à partir du moment où
une augmentation de l'espérance de vie
ça doit forcément se faire au travail ça
peut se faire justement dans leur peau
dans les activités d'un retraité merci
le quarante deux mille cent soixante
quatre matches et le fur oui alors j'ai
donné la parole à monsieur le furent
monsieur corbières je vous donne la
parole pour un rappel au règlement juste
après celle merci madame la présidente
nos travaux sont très observés et c'est
pour ça que je vous invite à être
l'attitude la plus la plus sérieuse qui
soir mais nos travaux sont très observé
c'est aussi positif parce que les gens
nous écrivent ils nous adressent des
mails nous adressent des courriers et
j'ai courrier j'ai reçu pour ma part un
courrier de marielle marielle a commencé
son itinéraire professionnel en faisant
des années au tuc
les tuk c'était les premiers les
premières mesures de traitement social
du chômage
c'était à l'époque de mythes rend donc
donc c'était les premiers systèmes
c'étaient les premiers systèmes il y en
a eu d'autres
et même si ça se ralentit du fait de la
situation économique il y en a encore
donc la question que pose tous ceux qui
ont connu plusieurs années de traitement
social du chômage c'est comment ils vont
être traitées en terme de retraites et
là monsieur minutes je veux que vous
soyez très précis puisque on a bien
compris qu'il y avait les générations
avant 75 les générations entre 75 et
2004 les générations après 2004
donc mon souci c'est un tableau à double
entrée en quelque sorte avec les
différents systèmes de traitement social
du chômage et avec les générations et je
veux savoir combien de points et combien
de trimestres
je veux comparer l'ancien système par
trimestre généralement ils arize arriver
malgré tout validé leurs trimestres par
rapport au point quand ils avaient
validé leur trimestre et admettons
qu'ils aient après un itinéraire de
salariés ordinaires
comment compter les 25 meilleures années
leur passage au tuc ou leur passage dans
différents systèmes de protection
sociale de traitement social du chômage
ne les pénalise et pas
or maintenant ils vont l'être ils vont
l'être nécessairement puisque s'ils sont
validés ils sont juste à la marge de la
validation donc combien ça vaut en terme
de points ma question est précise
j'attends de votre part monsieur le
ministre
une réponse précise en intégrant
génération et génération
vous avez bien compris ma demande de
tableau à double entrée venant la
présidente vous accordera à paper board
si c'est nécessaire
monsieur merci monsieur le
le député alors le 41e 1888 à la fusion
avec cet article sur lequel nous parlons
évidemment beaucoup de des critères de
pénibilité
on voit aussi qu'on touche à votre
conception de la liberté votre liberté
au travers de ce projet de loi c'est
permettre aux plus riches de s'enrichir
indéfiniment et pour tous les autres
c'est d'être acculé à donner tout de
leur vie pour tenter de la gagner et
c'est particulièrement vrai quand on
parle d'un certain nombre d'indépendants
on pense aux humeurs mais mais a plein
d'autres
votre promesse de liberté celle qui
consisterait à expliquer que l'affectif
bilité ou le statut de hub heures et
bien finalement ce serait la modernité
cette modernité qui est on le voit au
prix d'un abaissement de l'être humain
où l'emploi se muent chaque jour un peu
plus en marchandises ou les savoir faire
sont méprisés
mon collègue brunel parlé tout à l'heure
de ces aides à domiciles de ces femmes
qui travaillent quelques heures de
manière découpé dans la journée dont les
trajets les déplacements peuvent être
très longs se faire souvent en
transports en commun etc or là ne sont
pas comptés c'est or là où la plupart du
temps et bien on voit qu'elle rend elles
partent très tôt qu'elle revienne très
tard ou c'est compliqué souvent pour
s'occuper des enfants c'est vrai aussi
des hommes évidemment et on aspire à ce
qu'il s'en occupe plus également
mais on voit à quel point en tout cas
leur vie est rythmée par l'objectif de
rentabilité et qui épuisent leurs leur
énergie et leur vie alors finalement la
question c'est est-ce que vous avez
d'autres promesses que celle qui
consisterait à expliquer que l'état
n'apporte aucune garantie l'état
n'interviendra jamais pour elles et eux
et qu'il intervient finalement que pour
garantir des droits aux plus riches
d'entre d'entre eux merci madame la
députée le 41 1893 monsieur
oui merci madame la présidente devrait à
nouveau à nouveau remercier notre
collègue boris vallot pour cet
amendement qui défend le principe de non
régression sociale
je voudrais préciser la pensée que j'ai
essayé d'exprimer tout à l'heure sur la
logique de de productivité humaine en
fait un qui anime votre votre votre
texte qui anime un certain nombre de
projets que vous nous avez présenté est
d'ailleurs toujours plus de productivité
la travailler les seniors plus longtemps
cette mesure qui s'applique aussi pour
les indépendants évidemment entre eux
pour garantir leurs droits à la retraite
voudrais citer les orthophonistes qui
ont été très mobilisés
j'en profite pour vous dire qu'il ya en
ce moment une mobile une mobilisation
une manifestation dans les rues de
marseille et il y en aura une sans doute
dans les rues de 7,20 non us
cet après midi dans les rues de paris
pour continuer à protester contre contre
votre projet la mobilisation ne faiblit
pas et je suppose parce que je les avais
déjà croisé il ya quelques temps de cela
dans une manifestation que les
orthophonistes étaient présents je vais
vous lire le témoignage de delphine
orthophoniste qui dit la chose suivante
je voudrais m'installer dans mon propre
cabinet dans les prochaines années mais
avec la réforme je me pose pas mal de
questions si le taux de cotisation au
régime de retraite passe à 28 % au lieu
de 14
cela me ferait 7000 euros de charges en
plus par an alors que je paye aussi 500
euros par mois à l'urssaf
mais tout ça ça ne se limite pas aux
orthophonistes qui sont très mobilisés
qui sont une profession en souffrance
d'ailleurs on donnerait beaucoup besoin
l'hôpital est aujourd'hui et bien elles
en sont trop absents parce qu'on ne
donne pas les crédits suffisants pour
cela et les patients de l'hôpital ont
besoin de ces soins là françois kinésie
kinésithérapeute c'est la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase est ce que je
pourrai toujours consacré une demi heure
par patient ou alors est-ce qu'il faudra
que je prenne plus de patients en même
temps sinon leur consacrer seulement une
quinzaine de minutes
une autre manière de répercuter les
coûts seraient d'investia moins dans du
matériel ou de recourir à du dépassement
d'honoraires regrette-t-il
voilà par exemple les choses qu'on peut
entendre karine podologue pédicure
j'envisage soin de changer métier soit
de quitter la france donc vous voyez
bien qu'avec ce que vous nous dites là
vous n'êtes pas au bout de la réponse
aux questions qui sont posées pour les
indépendants et pour un certain nombre
d'entre vous aggravé leur situation
ex'im monsieur le député le 41 1897
monsieur dharréville également monsieur
jumelles
s'il vous plaît monsieur 15,9 et madame
la présidente moi je n'ai pas vocation à
chauffer la salle
mais par contre quand j'entends des
insultes aussi valorisante pour les
membres de la majorité
monsieur monsieur sumer surjoue pas là
ma culture où pâturent ben ma culture ne
me conduit pas à tendre la joue gauche
d'autant que vous dites on dialogue on
concertent en fait vous fait des ronds
dans l'eau et et ça n'aboutit à rien
mais en même temps que vous faites ça je
veux attirer votre attention sur le fait
que le dialogue social pour les
marcheurs c'est les discriminations
sociales qui chaque jour syndicale qui
chaque jour se multiplient un peu plus
des électriciens gaziers ont reçu des
lettres de mise en demeure de menaces
d'entretiens préalables avant sanction
disciplinaire parce qu'ils ont
l'outrecuidance de protester ou de
résister à votre mauvais projets dans de
nombreuses pme dans de nombreuses pmi
des salariés qui n'ont pas
d'organisations syndicales se voit
convoqué parce qu'ils ont eu la
faiblesse d'utiliser le droit
constitutionnel à manifester c'est vous
dire que votre discours sur le dialogue
social sur le respect sur votre volonté
de continuer à concerter la nation n'a
aucun sens dans la réalité des habitants
que nous rencontrons monsieur le
ministre si vous voulez que ce projet de
loi continue de se dérouler dans la
sérénité pouvez-vous nous informait de
la manière dont le gouvernement va
garantir dans les boîtes dans les
services publics l'exercice libre de
cette liberté constitutionnelle du droit
de manifester du droit de s'opposer à un
projet de réforme en démocratie ça nous
semble élémentaire j'aimerais vous
entendre sur cette question
le 41 1901 alors qui de vous monsieur
brunel
mais
merci à un président mon collègue et mes
collègues vraiment pire darvill vous
voulez et exprime les courriers qui
qu'il a reçus donc les craintes les
réflexions que se posent notamment les
kinés les infirmiers etc
et là j'entends une rumeur dans la salle
alors on nous demande de débat sur le
fond on apporte des éléments de
questionnements de crainte de personnes
qui disent est ce que je vais encore
rester à dans ce pays pour faire ma
fonction et là il ya un tollé général
quand même ça ça va pas parce que si on
veut travailler sur le fond pour le
savoir a coûté aussi ce qu'ils expriment
notamment les citoyens et qui est con on
est con on est con relais ici dans cet
hémicycle ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose vient aussi parler des
grandes manifestations qui ont lu encore
aujourd'hui donc des personnes qui on
n'est pas d'accord avec la réforme que
vous proposez et donc nous on veut vous
retirer cette réforme et en même temps
on est dans ce pays où la liberté
il ya beaucoup de d'atteintes aux
libertés
je pense notamment à la sncf où il ya
des primes au mérite à ceux qui ne font
pas grève
il ya des pressions énormes qui se
réalise aussi pour ceux qui veulent
faire grève dans les entreprises
et ça c'est intolérable au moment on se
dit à un pays des droits de l'homme
un pays où la liberté d'expression
existe aujourd'hui on est en train de
faire taire cette liberté est
heureusement qu'il ya des manifestations
qui sont là pour dire nous on ne
laissera pas faire on ira jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est aussi notre avis une
haute opinion et on veut être respecté
merci monsieur le député le 42 1193
madame le fiat merci madame la
présidente
donc par cet amendement nous souhaitons
compliqué l'amendement de monsieur
vallot par les ceux du soin parce que
dans les professions libérales faudrait
pas oublier les professions du soin et
quand mon collègue parle tout à l'heure
de profession qui pourrait partir à
l'étranger effectivement on a entendu
des gens faire oh là là quand on habite
la lorraine comme moi ils sont déjà
partis en belgique au luxembourg et
c'est un secret pour personne
j'ai donc ne faites pas vous étonner
enfin chez nous les libéraux les
orthophonistes les podologues les kinés
sont déjà partis au luxembourg et en
belgique
donc si ça n'est pas encore arrivé dans
vos circonscriptions ça ne serait tarder
avec votre projet de loi donc ce serait
bien de prendre en compte quand on vous
alerte sur des sujets qui sont fortement
inquiétant les soignants sont en grève
depuis 11 mois
on a bien du mal de les entendre dans
entendre parler parce que il continue la
continuité des soins existent et c'est
une loi dans notre pays
mais il faut bien entendre leurs
inquiétudes et on ne parle tout le temps
dans cet hémicycle des déserts médicaux
votre projet de loi va faire qu'aggraver
la situation des déserts médicaux dans
notre pays je vous alerte sur la
situation
monsieur le ministre lors en commission
vous m'avez souvent répondu de faire
confiance aux partenaires sociaux et que
les discussions avaient lieu les
partenaires sociaux monsieur le ministre
on les a rencontrés et les discussions
bien ils savent pas avec qui vous les
avez pas ce qu'en tout cas eux n'ont pas
eu cette conversation avec vous ses
discussions avec vous donc pas que je
met votre parole en doute mais là il ya
inquiétude donc si on pouvait en savoir
plus sur ces discussions et avec qui
elles ont eu lieu parce que là ça nous
intéresserait vraiment suis madame
beaucoup
le sous-amendement 42 1073 monsieur le
fur oui cet homme ce sous-amendement
mais je me dis ça me permet d'avoir une
précision sur les assistantes
maternelles vous nous avez expliqué mais
ça peut valoir pour d'autres professions
vous nous avez expliqué que ces
personnes bénéficieraient des 85% du
smig
quels que soient leur itinéraire
professionnel je prends l'exemple de
l'assistante maternelle mais ça peut
valoir pour d'autres professions qui
pour partie de son activité n'a eu qu'un
enfant donc été attire tant à mi-temps
en quelque sorte
donc cette personne comment est-elle
éligibles aux 85% du smic puisqu'elle
n'a pas une carrière complète à plein
temps
moi j'avais compris que c'était carrière
complète à plein temps si vous nous
dites ces carrières complètes à mi temps
pourquoi pas mais ça m'étonnerait quand
même je prends quelqu'un qui avait une
existence complète à mi temps est-ce
qu'il a le droit ou 85% du smig
si vous me le dit très bien mais ça me
surprendrait un peu quand même hein donc
monsieur le ministre
soit vous nous avez raconté des choses
qui n'étaient pas tout à fait convenable
je reste extrêmement poli mais on
comprend la fatigue les multiples
documents les multiples fiche on vous en
veux pas le sujet c'est que je voudrais
que maintenant vous nous disiez très
concrètement est-ce que d'assistantes
maternelles qui n'a pas tout au long de
son existence eu les trois enfants
permettant le trou plein où les quatre
enfants permettant le taux plein est ce
que cette personne
au terme de son existence
professionnelle en admettant qu'elle ait
fait les quarante et quelques années est
ce qu'elle aura le droit où 85% du smig
merci de répondre précisément à cette
question que je crois précise merci
monsieur le fur alors avant de donner la
parole à monsieur le rapporteur je suis
saisie de cette demande de scrutin
public sur les sous-amendement suivant
le 42 1206 par le groupe france
insoumise le 41 1869 par
groupe gdr le 41 1886 par le groupe gdr
le 42 milles 203 par les groupes
français soumise et gdr le 42 1164 par
le groupe gdr le 41 1888 par le groupe
gdr et le 42 1193 par le groupe france
insoumise la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la présidente plusieurs
députés ont rappelé à travailler sur le
fond et c'est ce que je
je vous invite à faire les uns et les
autres et pour moi travailler sur le
fond c'est travailler sur le texte est
sûr travaillé sur le texte des
amendements en l'occurrence l'amendement
de monsieur vélo et 2 c et de ses
collègues à l'amendement précédent qui
était sur les indépendants le groupe gdr
a parlé des avocats qui sont des
libéraux est là à l'amendement sur les
libéraux vous nous parler des
indépendants et vous nous parler des
verriers qui sont ou des indépendants ou
des salariés vous nous avez parlé des
aides à domicile qui ne sont pas des
libéraux
vous nous avez parlé des 11es h ou des
atsem qui ne sont pas des libéraux est
ce que nous pourrions nous consacrer aux
libéraux qui mérite une attention toute
particulière mettre sur le fond voilà
donc sur les libéraux sur les libéraux
et je vais apporter des éléments sur les
libéraux sur les libéraux qui sont
répartis en dix sections au sein de la
cnaf pl et ses dix sections s'appuie sur
un système et de base et complémentaires
par points donc c'est le système que
nous proposons donc à la base il utilise
le mode par point sur leurs régimes de
base et sur leurs systèmes
complémentaires pour les avocats qui ne
sont pas dans la cnav pl ils ont un
système de base par trimestre un système
complémentaire par point je voulais
faire ces précisions ça me semblait
intéressant je rappelle d'ailleurs que
les caisses actuellement gestionnaire de
la retraite des professions libérales le
resteront demain et qu'un conseil de la
protection sociale des professions
libérales sera créé pour qu'ils soient
représentés au sein de la seine et rue
et que leurs intérêts leurs spécificités
ils soient particulièrement défendue
donc c'est des éléments qui me semblait
important de préciser sur sur les
orthophonistes qui ont été cités je cite
simplement que leurs cotisations à eux
vont baisser de 8,8 pour cent pour cent
avec la réforme par rapport à la
filiation karpenko donc il ya aussi
cette phase de transition et qui pour
certains va mener à des à des
progressions et pour d'autres à des
baisses pour être dans un régime dans un
régime commun et puis
pour répondre précisément monsieur le
furent même si c'est pas si c'est pas
l'objet de cet amendement puisque les
assistantes maternelles ne sont pas des
libérales mais pour répondre à monsieur
le fur qui interrogé pour avoir le droit
aux mikko à 85% il faut avoir cotisé sur
la base de 600 heures smic c'est à dire
l'équivalent d'un tiers temps donc qui
est en général largement compatible avec
l'activité des assistantes maternelles
donc un tiers-temps 600 heures smic
permet ça représente 50 heures par mois
intertan voilà cinquante heures smic
cela fait 600 heures smic à l'année
voilà donc j'ai apporté ces précisions
et donc sur les amendements sur
l'amendement de fond de monsieur vélo et
de ses collègues il sera abordé à
l'article 4 donc je vous demande un
retrait ou à défaut défavorables et les
soins
merci monsieur le rapporteur messieurs
les ministres nationaux mme la
présidente mais messieurs les députés
alors on va d'accord consacrer du temps
à l'amendement mais il ya moult
sous-amendement et moult sujets puisque
sur le fond
moi j'avais lu l'amendement jerry porter
de l'intérêt
je m'étais dit qu'un on parle des
professions libérales des libéraux j'ai
fait comme le rapporteur je me tiens
tout le monde va se consacrer à ce sujet
là puisque on puisse à ce sujet quel est
l'intérêt c'est tout le monde qui en
fait pas du tout ce qu'ils nous disent
il ya une demi-heure où il ya une heure
qui sont très intéressés par les
professions libérales
lorsqu'il ya un amendement sur les
professions libérales parle de tout
autre chose que les professions
libérales
donc j'imagine que là il ya exactement
parce que c'est c'est la fin de matinée
les notes j'ai dû perdre un petit peu le
fil des choses mais je pense que la
réalité c'est que d'autres n'y ont pas
été attentif alors monsieur le député
pierre dharréville c'est comme vous avez
je vais même pas compter le nombre de
sous-amendements qu'à chaque fois vous
intervenez sur un sous-amendement vous
me posez une question différente c'est à
dire que c'est un petit peu comme si
vous étiez ou questions au gouvernement
sauf que vous aviez déplafonné comme ce
sera le cas pour le compte pénibilité le
nombre de questions auxquelles vous avez
droit
alors je vais je vais essayer monsieur
monsieur le député pierre dharréville
d'y répondre et vous comprenez que c'est
difficile d'être exhaustif parce que
vous avez des prises de paroles très
conséquente et avec qualité et donc il
me faut du coup y consacrer un petit peu
de temps sur le haut tout d'abord sur le
taux de rendement il y aura vous avez
d'ailleurs c'était indiqué ça a été
précisée vous m'avez interrogé sur les
taux de rendement c'était déjà le cas
dans un rapport de le voir taux de
rendement était indiquée 5 5% de toi le
rendement brut
c'est connu il n'y avait pas de sujet là
dessus comment ce taux de rendement
était garanti bien et des garanties
parce que vous l'avez aussi vu verser
dans le projet de loi
1 les valeurs d'achat et de service du
point sont indexés de la même façon donc
ça sécurise le taux de rendement est là
dessus vous avez eu un débat avec nous
en commission d'ailleurs justement pour
savoir sur quoi était-il
indexer ces valeurs d'achat de services
et vous avez d'ailleurs sans doute vu
récemment que la haute autorité de la
statistique qui a effectivement souligné
qu'il était tout à fait possible de
composer un indice sur le revenu moyen
par tête et que tout cela pourrait se
faire en toute indépendance et donc
j'imagine que vous êtes parfaitement
rassurés sur le sujet vous avez aussi
poser des questions sur sur les réserves
moi je ne me lasse pas de le dire et de
le redire j'entends que il faut
continuer à réaffirmer cela les réserves
d'ailleurs ça a été soulignée par je
crois madame dalloz un moment donné
parce qu'elle connaît le droit et
qu'elle a souligné le droit de propriété
sont et resteront la propriété de ceux
qui les ont constitué il ya pas de débat
sur le sujet peut pas en avoir ailleurs
donc le sujet est très claire on
m'interpellait et vous-même et madame
dalloz m'interpréter sur le fait que oui
mais j'avais conduit un un amendement du
gouvernement en commission
merci de souligner qu'il ya eu des
travaux en commissions qui auraient été
d'ailleurs bien qu'il soit peut-être
plus ramassé pour qu'on vienne avec le
texte en hémicycle
mais j'avais conduit un amendement en
commission qui permettait justement à la
fois d'expliquer cette réalité des
réserves est de donner la possibilité la
possibilité pour les caisses qui le
déciderai c'est à dire pour ceux qui en
sont les propriétaires de couvrir pour
tout ou partie éventuellement une
progression qui pourrait être existantes
dans certaines catégories de charges
voilà ni plus ni moi c'est une option
une possibilité qui est donné et comme
ce sont les propriétaires de ces
réserves qui décideront eh bien je crois
qu'il faut leur faire confiance pour
savoir ce qu'ils décideront d'enfer et
arrêter de préjuger de ce qu'il voudrait
en faire monsieur pierre dharréville
avec votre collègue madame la députée
faucillon vous vous êtes inquiétée à
plusieurs reprises du statut d auto
entrepreneur alors comme vous êtes
intervenu je l' ai dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est moi je n'interviens pas à
chaque fois derrière vous donc
laissez moi le temps d'intervenir pour
vous répondre que si chaque fois que
vous intervenez vous deux ou trois fois
la suite et que la troisième fois vous
dit le ministre a pas répondu bah oui
c'est compliqué puisque le ministre
attend que madame la présidente tu
passes ta parole parce qu'il est
respectueux du fonctionnement de cette
institution alors sur le statut d auto
entrepreneur
si et je sais que c'est votre volonté je
n'en doute pas ainsi que celle des
membres de votre groupe
nous allons pouvoir en discuter assez
largement à l'article 22 mais je ne veux
pas simplement vous renvoyer à l'article
22 je vais vous donner quelques éléments
parce que je sais que c'est cela que
vous vous attendez bien les
auto-entrepreneurs se verront dans le
cadre de ce projet doit offrir la
possibilité de cotiser à hauteur de 600
heures smic ce qui fait écho à ce que
vient de dire l'excellent rapporteur de
la thur croire en réponse à monsieur le
député marc le fur mais qui nous
écoutent plus parce qu'il est je pense
dans une autre réflexion mais je pense
que dans une réflexion importante
les six ans de smic en la matière et
bien permet trop s'ils le souhaitent aux
auto-entrepreneurs donc de cotiser sur
indigo qui leur donnerait accès de 4.50
118 donc le sujet des auto entrepreneurs
il est traité dans l'article 22 et il
correspondra à la même possibilité il
n'y avait pas de taquineries c'est parce
que j'essayais de voiliers j'essaie
quand même de répondre à tout le monde
donc je vois là j'entends j'entends
c'est à vous c'est le député le fur
ce que je voulais dire c'est que sur le
fond les deux questions pouvaient se
rejoint c'était en cela que je me
retournais vers vous et à la fois la
question des auto entrepreneurs dont
l'option sera offert de cotiser à
hauteur de 600 au smic et donc de
bénéficier du minimum de pension qui
faisait l'objet de cette question que
vous posiez pour les assistantes
maternelles et monsieur le rapporteur
nicolas turquois a rappelé que dans le
système universel de retraite nous il
est excellent match l'entente
le rapporteur mais comme tous ceux qui
vont se succéder à ce banc après eh bien
ils auront la possibilité elles auront
ce sont des assistantes maternelles la
possibilité effectivement d'accéder au
minimum de pension à 85% du smic parce
que la plupart du temps effectivement à
50 heures smic par mois
c'est le tiers c'est le tiers grosso
modo du smic temps complet on rentre on
rentre dans les droits pour les 85% du
smic ce ce le sujet je me retourne vers
vers pierre dharréville même aux
questions au gouvernement il ya un petit
peu de formalisme on parle les uns près
des autres pas faire une discussion
comme ça j'essaie de répondre de façon
circonstanciée étayé pardonné le fait
que je redonne ma pensée monsieur le
député pierre dharréville vous vous
intéressez à l'espérance de vie dans une
de vos nombreuses interventions
précédentes
non pas que je les trouve trop
nombreuses mais je constate qu'elles
sont nombreuses
c'est intéressant il y avait un débat je
crois que je crois que c'est le
président eric woerth a dit un mot
là-dessus et je pense que c'est le
député eric dont cyrille isaac sybille
qui a dit un autre mot sur le sujet en
matière d'espérance de vie en bonne
santé disant que sur les aspects
déclaratif
il fallait regarder ça de façon
relativement prudente car nous avons du
mal à rentrer dans une comparaison avec
des critères objectifs me semble que ce
sont les deux députés qui sont
intervenus sur le sujet moi je vous
propose de regarder des éléments
objectifs
si on regarde depuis 1945
l'insee nous dit qu'en 2040
l'espérance de vie par rapport à
aujourd'hui
on va progresser à sera de plus trois
ans et demi pour les hommes de plus deux
ans et demi pour les femmes
même s'il ya une probation de plus
importante pour les hommes que pour les
femmes
nous voyons que la dynamique de
progression d'espérance de vie continue
et peut-être qu'on pourrait prendre à un
indicateur objectif c'est l'espérance de
vie sans incapacité à 65 ans puisque
l'incapacité allé constaté par un
médecin donc cet objectif c'est pas une
question de rapport employeur versus
salariés c'est une question fait
appel à quelqu'un dont c'est le métier
un médecin et qu'ils se prononcent sur
l'incapacité qu'est ce que nous voyons
sur cette incapacité en tout cas
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité à 65
ans c'est qu'elle a progressé d'un an et
de 2 mois pour les hommes et de 1 an et
de 5 points pour les femmes et donc la
référence
oui c'est compliqué et chantons ce que
vous voulez dire j'entends que vous
voulez plutôt mettre l'accent sûr la
notion des conditions d'exercice des
activités et de la pénibilité j'entends
que vous vouliez parler de ça mais
parlons de cela restons sur des éléments
qui sont objectifs et mesurables
d'ailleurs à ce propos de d'éléments
objectifs et mesurables
le député jumelles qui connaît bien son
territoire à qui nous fait partager
régulièrement les rencontres qu'il y
fait nous parle des verriers et nous
parle de la température au pied du four
j'entends j'entends cela et vous savez
je crois que tous ceux qui sont dans des
territoires où notamment il y a eu tout
il ya de la sidérurgie ou des mines
savent aussi la difficulté qu'il y à
autre à vay quel que soit le bord
politique où les sont assis ici
mais j'entends que vous fassiez cette
remarque et sur le fond pourquoi je
rebondis dessus en dehors du fait que il
est normal que je vous apporte une
réponse parce que c'est typiquement
typiquement puisque c'est le cas
l'exposition à des températures élevées
ou faible un élément qui est pris en
compte dans la pénibilité
donc ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui sera
soumis régulièrement à des températures
importantes et vous le vérifier
vous-même dans le compte professionnel
de prévention bénéficiera de points
pénibilité et pourra partir plus tôt en
retraite et jusqu'à deux ans plus tôt
donc voyez on ne sera pas à 67 ans comme
vous aviez fait l'hypothèse tout à
l'heure je voudrais également vous
remercier pour le suivi médiatique que
vous nous faites de la conférence de
financement et et en même temps parce
que moi aussi je lis les journaux et je
vois que
vous avez une lecture assidue de tout
cela mais je reconnais que vous êtes
plusieurs sur ses bancs à la voir et pas
que vous et sur le fond je trouve que
c'est un bon indicateur ça veut dire que
la démocratie politique que vous
représentez s'intéressent au
fonctionnement de la démocratie sociale
et c'est pas moi qui vais trouver que
cela soit une mauvaise chose mais en
même temps il peut être que nous pouvons
aussi dire ici que si l'ensemble des
députés que vous êtes représente la
démocratie politique
il faut peut-être aussi envisager de
laisser la démocratie sociale le temps
de construire ait accepté qu'il y a
aussi des prises de position dans cette
démocratie sociale comme il ya ici dans
cet hémicycle des prises de position et
parfois même des prises de bec et bien
il ya dans la démocratie sociale aussi
des positions qui se construisent mais
qui ouvre la voie
je l'espère et je ferai tout pour cela à
une concertation qui donnera au final un
compromis de qualité il y à une madame
la présidente un certain nombre
d'interventions en sous-amendement sur
les orthophonistes je préparais ce sujet
et puis en même temps j'étais j'étais
dans la lecture j'essaye d'anticiper un
des amendements suivant malgré
l'inquiétude qu'a le député le fur sur
ma capacité à écouter et à prendre la
parole à proximité de l'heure du repas
mais je vous rassure monsieur le député
elle est excellente cette capacité et je
me disais mais tiens c'est intéressant
parce que je vois que l'amendement
suivant madame la présidente porte
exactement sur ce sujet des intervenants
des orthophonistes vous irez vous voyez
à transformer oui je vous le moment là
oui voila j'ai donné un avis défavorable
à tout cela bien mes chers collègues
oui juste une chose il est presque
l'heure de la clôture je penserai
préférable de clore cette série par les
interventions et les votes
donc je vais donner la parole à monsieur
coquerel pour un rappel au règlement
mais j'assume les orateurs
j'incite les orateurs à être synthétique
dans leurs interventions
oui monsieur coquerel a rappelé le
règlement sur qu'elle fonde sur
l'article sans se lier à 5 sur la clarté
la socialité débat hier et aujourd'hui
avec justesse
nos camarades communistes expliqué être
subir un traitement particulier de la
présidence de l'assemblée sur leurs
amendements nous
estimant avoir un traitement particulier
de la part du ministre parce que moi
j'observe que depuis hier il n'y a pas
une seule réponse qui est donné aux
questions que tout le faisons hier j'ai
fait les j'ai fait l'expérience sur la
question sur la question du salaire
portés aux comptes à 50% ou j'ai posé
une question précise
là nous avons une série d'amendements
notamment sur les questions d'espérance
de vie
monsieur pietra chef qui à chaque fois
ne répond jamais je ne sais pas si c'est
une stratégie vis-à-vis de france a
soumises pour laisser penser comme nous
l'entendons les médias que nous
compterions d'une paralysie haute alors
que tous nos amendements sont
argumentées avec des questions très
précises mais ça serait bien que ces
discriminations cesse bien monsieur le
monsieur le député il n'appartient pas à
la présidence de dicter au ministre ses
paroles je pense que le ministre fort de
votre intervention reviendra sur les
questions vous avez évoqué mais chevalot
vous souhaitez faire un rappel au
règlement sur quel fondement sur le
fondement de l'article sans vous pourra
pour abonder dans le sens des exigences
de qualité du débat démocratique je sais
que ce n'est pas votre prérogatives mais
c'est une occasion pour moi de dire au
ministre qu'à des questions précises ils
pourraient j'allais dire s'astreindre
même en ordonnant sens à penser à des
réponses qui le soit aussi
il ya des questions qui sont
continuellement posée depuis maintenant
près de deux jours complets et on n'a
toujours pas de réponse
songez que sur le plan de l'obligation
faite sur le plan constitutionnel à
l'exécutif de décrire leur
représentation nationale on est sûr de
l'éclairage basse tension on la voyait
alors monsieur verte
après
merci madame la présidente s'il vous
plaît je note que chacun cherche à
garantir quelque chose garantir la
pension future garantir la gtz et on
voit bien que dans le système actuel
c'est très difficile et dans le système
futur ce sera tout aussi difficile car
c'était la recherche de l'impossible à
un moment donné
donc il ya lorsque vous nous dites qu'il
est garanti et des garanties par les
mots n'y a pas de garantie par les fêtes
et ce sera la réalité puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de variables d'ajustement
un mot sur les caisses autonomes et
notamment les avocats si vous voulez
prendre le régime des avocats doit être
dans le régime universel
alors il faut aussi à un moment donné
que vous dit qu'il ya la démographie et
est bonne pour eux maintenant et donc
ils doivent contribuer à la solidarité
ce qu'ils font déjà d'ailleurs il faut à
ce moment-là prendre tout le régime des
avocats et notamment le fait que les
avocats et notamment que les avocats par
deux ans plus tard que le rêve que la
moyenne des français donc preuve prenez
l'ensemble ne prenez pas qu'une seule
partie
troisième point l'histoire des détroits
à 8 plafond de sécurité sociale
moi j'ai regardé les choses je vous
l'avais dit en 2018 c'était quelque
chose qui était positive pour le régime
en réalité les cotisations étaient plus
fortes que les pensions en 2050 c'est
exactement le cas dans toutes les
prévisions qui sont faites sur le
périmètre agirc arrco donc on peut se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi
vous faites cela pourquoi vous vous
rendez vous rendait impossible de
cotiser au delà de trois passes alors
que entre 3 et 8 passes a priori le
niveau des pensions est inférieure au
niveau des cotisations dons qu'il est là
c'est assez curieux en réalité d'agir
d'agir ainsi président verte monsieur
bah là non je rappelle que j'invite
chacun la conclusion ce n'est pas une
disposition avant d'aborder le fond la
forme juste par exemple j'ai demandé la
parole mais c'est pas vous madame la
présidente c'est l'enchaînement des
amendements ou des sous-amendements et
monsieur jumelles que j'aime beaucoup il
le sait va interpeller m'a dit monsieur
bah là non prenez la parole
ça faisait déjà une heure et demie que
j'avais demandé la parole et pour j'ai
demandé la parole à 10 heures il est
13h15 et tout ça à cause de votre
enchaînement de sous-amendements donc
c'est la règle du jeu et je ne la
critique pas je la constate mais arrêtez
ne nous dit pas après que vous êtes
bâillonnés que l'opposition ne peut pas
s'exprimer en ce moment c'est la
majorité qui peut pas s'exprimer
venant en venons en au fond d'eux
venons-en au fond maintenant venant au
fond maintenant eux
on a eu un long moment où on a beaucoup
parlé des indépendants et des libéraux
bon on en
on en parle beaucoup je ne suis pas sûr
que tout le monde connaisse vraiment la
réalité du travail d'un indépendant et
la réalité de la situation des
indépendants moi je jeu j'ai été
indépendant quasiment toute ma vie avant
d'être député c'est quoi un indépendant
c'est quoi un indépendant et je suis
aussi monsieur coquerel toujours
politiquement c'est quoi un indépendant
c'est quelqu'un qui prend des risques
qui crée parfois des entreprises qui
parfois souvent créé de l'emploi qui
aujourd'hui dans notre modèle vous
m'écoutez monsieur jumelles s'il vous
plaît qui occupent qui aujourd'hui dans
notre modèle qui a qui aujourd'hui dans
notre modèle n'ont aucune protection
que se passe-t-il aujourd'hui on a parlé
aussi des de libéralisation etc
et c'est un vrai sujet